Happy New Year can you believe it's
already been 10 years since ten years
ago okay so I hope you all had a fun and
safe New Year's party yep
playing it safe which is why I'm putting
up my New Year's video on the second the
first I love New Year's and this is why
because it is the one time that
everybody lies their ass off to
themselves and nobody knocks anyone for
it it's just understood it is the way
New Year's resolutions yeah New Year's
resolutions would be better called a
list of [ __ ] you're guaranteed not to do
that year because we all do it we set
new year's resolutions and flake out on
them and then you feel like [ __ ] you
feel like a jackass you feel like just
half the man you should be like if you
said a new year's resolution to quit
smoking you quit for like a day and then
you throw in the towel unlike by today
let's be honest when it comes to New
Year's resolutions the exact opposite of
what you promised to happen actually
happens it's almost like if you set a
new year's resolution to smoke a pack a
day you'll quit cold-turkey by the 24
premier guaranteed I don't know what
you're thinking that's got you thinking
yes try some reverse psychology on your
resolution that's right flip that [ __ ]
hey this [ __ ] works you were about to
enter the advanced psychological world
of Jeremy bland like okay if your goal
is to catch up on the show lost before
the premiere your resolution should be
to never watch an episode of lost ever
especially before the premiere if the
pattern is the same you'll be caught up
by the 23rd of this month
guaranteed done oh yeah I have thought
this [ __ ] through fry it on anything you
want to work out and get cut by summer
just be like I promise never to work out
and get in shape in 2010 you'll be
ironing off your abs by spring you want
to get along with your neighbors more
you should say I will hate my neighbors
on a daily basis and pray for their
demise you'll be having barbecues on the
first day of June you want to whack it
less this year just be like you know you
don't want to overdo it you know just we
already got to just stop it to you two
it's plenty three resolutions and
that's a bit much you just don't want to
fail it's only 2010 after all it's not
like it's 2000 78,000 it's motivational
video after all I'm not a unrealistic
video but in any case I'm telling you
try this [ __ ] this logic is there -
that's right for New Year's I give you
pearls and again I hope you had a fun
and not too incriminating New Year's but
if you happen to record yourself doing
anything particularly stupid well upload
that [ __ ] because if you don't one of
your friends will and whatever your
resolutions were I wish you all the luck
in fulfilling them because if there's
one thing I've learned is that life is
too short and you just want to have any
regrets so if you've wanted to go
skydiving this is the year you're gonna
do it if you've been thinking for a
while now to start your own internet
video chat channel do it if you've
wanted to talk to or make a move on that
girl for the longest time do it
because if that doesn't work out odds
are she probably has hot friends and now
you've just fallen into a back-up plan
you see you've become assertive and
you've learned to plan ahead all in one
year you are a new man like I said
pearls as for me I'm gonna bring you
guys more videos more frequently because
this one video a week [ __ ] I'm doing it
for me you guys deserve more and yes
before you leave be sure to click on the
link in the sidebar and click subscribe
to subscribe to my channel it's gonna be
a good year